in einem sind wir uns wohl alle einig
bolognesellensky Bar und ist der Mann
des Jahres 2022 der Held der Stunde
silensky verdient unsere ganze
Bewunderung diejenigen von euch die
diesen Kanal schon lange verfolgen
wissen sogar dass wir ihm im Jahr zuvor
also bereits 2021 den isualpolitik im
Wort verliehen haben ja genau wir haben
auch selenskis besondere Bedeutung
bereits hingewiesen als nur wenige ihn
auf dem Schirm hatten oder überhaupt
richtig wussten wer eigentlich ist
aber eines vorab wie alle Politiker ist
der Präsident der Ukraine natürlich auch
nicht perfekt aber die Tatsache dass er
der russischen Invasion so heldenhaft
widerstanden hat und dann weiterhin die
Stellen bietet hat ihn zu einem Anführer
von Weltrang gemacht dem ein Platz in
den Geschichtsbüchern sicher ist wir
müssen uns jedoch auch darüber im Klaren
sein dass dies für ihn kein
Freifahrtschein auf ewig sein kann schon
gar nicht wenn man bedenkt dass ein
erster Linie Politiker ist denn denen
sollte man immer genau auf die Finger
sehen man darf sich nie in einen
Politiker verlieben so sehr selensky
also ganz zu Recht unseren Beifall
verdient es wäre ein Grube Fehler eine
politische Figur die ihn zu vergöttern
deshalb wollen wir ihn in diesem Video
einmal ganz nüchtern unter die Lupe
nehmen
und eines müssen wir gleich vorab
anerkennen dieser Mann hat eine der
unwahrscheinlichsten Lebensgeschichten
die wir je gesehen haben sein Lebenslauf
steckt panlich voller Überraschung wollt
ihr ein Beispiel nun im Moment sehen wir
ihn ja als Putins großen widersache
silensky hat im Mai 2019 die
Präsidentenwahl in der Ukraine jedoch
deshalb gewonnen weil er der neutralste
Kandidat war also eine Art
Kompromisslösung ein Mittelding zwischen
all denen die dafür plädierten sich
weiterhin nach Moskau zu orientieren und
diejenigen die sich lieber auf den
besten konzentrieren wollten die Fragen
die wir uns heute stellen lauten also
die konnte dieser spitzbubi wirkende
Komiker überhaupt Präsident seines
Landes werden wie sah seine Politik in
der Ukraine vor den Krieg aus welche
Erfolge hat er versucht und welche
Fehler hat er gemacht heute werden wir
all diese Fragen beantworten aber zuerst
wollen wir wie bei uns üblich einen
Blick in die Geschichte werfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
selinski gewann vor vier Jahren die
Präsidentenwahl nachdem er in einer
bekannten Comedy-Serie ein naiven aber
ehrlichen Lehrer gespielt hatte der
durch Zufall ukrainischer Präsident
wurde das bedeutet logischerweise dass
viele sich schwer taten ihn überhaupt
ernst zu nehmen als er dann auch im
echten Leben die Wahlen gewann so weit
hergeholt ist auch klingen mag man
könnte sagen dass er Lenski oder
ehemalige us-präsidential Dragon einiges
gemeinsam haben die erste Ähnlichkeit
ist offensichtlich beide wurden zu
Medien Stars bevor sie den Sprung in die
Politik wagten genau darauf spielte auch
Putin an als diese Lenski die Wahl
gewonnen
er ist nur ein Schauspieler und wenn man
jemanden spielt heißt das nicht dass man
jemand wird Vladimir Putin
valodimizielle Ski wurde 1978 in krewi
rich geboren in einer großen
Industriestadt die damals wie die ganze
Ukraine Teil des Sowjetunion war wenn
diese Stadt die ziemlich genau in der
Mitte der Ukraine liegt damals in
Deutschland überhaupt jemanden ein
Begriff war dann unter dem russischen
Namen kryol Rock und Janna salewskys
Muttersprache ist nicht okrainisch
sondern russisch
er wuchs in einer akademiker-familie auf
sein Vater alexander war Wissenschaftler
als Mathematiker leitete er die
Computerabteilung einer großen
Universität seine Mutter immer ist
Ingenieurin und wie ihr Mann stammt sie
aus einer jüdischen Familie
dieser Lenski mit seiner beidseitigen
jüdischen Abstammung ist also der erste
jüdische Präsident in der ukrainischen
Geschichte ein Fakt der sich schon
ziemlich beißt mit dem Holzhammer
Argument von Putins Propaganda Apparat
und den herrscheren von grandetrollen
die ihn und die ganze ukrainische
Führung gerne als Nazis abholen am Rande
seiner bemerkt dass wolle die mehr die
ukrainische Stadt und Sprechweise von
Wladimir ist die unversöhnlichen
Kriegsgegner Putin und selenski sind
jedoch nicht nur Namensvetter gemein ist
den beiden Präsidenten auch ihr Hang
sich dramatisch und filmreif als
charismatische Führer inszene zu setzen
so gesehen handelt es sich bei beiden um
wirklich gewiefte Schulmänner die ist
sogar zu sexymbolen geschafft haben der
an dieser Stelle fangen jedoch die
gravierenden Unterschiede zwischen
beiden an denn während bei Putin dieser
Status nur auf oberflächliche
Inszenierung und reingespielten
Heldentum beruht hat ihn sich selenski
durch waren Mut verdient während sich
der eine in seinem Bunker oder hinter
sechs Meter lange Tischen Verkauf zeigte
letzte hat demonstrativ dass er auch in
Stunde allergrößter Gefahr bereit ist
sein persönliches Leben für Volk und
Vaterland zu opfern aber dazu später
mehr aber wenn wir schon bei visuellen
Unterschieden sind was meint ihr wer von
beiden der attraktive Mann ist das meine
ich durchaus ernst schließlich beruht
Politik in starkem Maße auch Psychologie
der Beeinflussung von Wahrnehmung und
viel anderen Unterbewussten Elementen
was meint ihr in die Beispiel das
Aussehen eines Politikers eine Rolle
welchen Unterschied in der Wahrnehmung
der Menschen macht selensky drei Tage
Bart um seine volle Mädel gegenüber dem
glatt rasierten Putin mit dreiviertel
Glatze nun ja ich wette das es sich bei
diesem Unterschied um keinen Zufall
handelt beide haben sich bewusst für
ihre jeweilige Erscheinungsform
entschieden um ein bestimmtes Image in
den Köpfen der Menschen zu erzeugen
schreibt uns doch in die Kommentare
welche Wirkung dies auf euch hat und
wenn wir schon beim Thema Wirkung durch
gutes Aussehen sind wir haben passend
dazu einen neuen Sponsoren die
haarklinik Hamed in Mannheim diese ist
allen Menschen die unter ganzen Bildung
oder schütterem haarleiden oder
natürlich aufgrund von Kopfverletzungen
Haare verloren haben es werden sogar
badtransplantationen angeboten das
50-köpfige Team von harmeck mit
international ausgezeichneten
FachärztInnen hat bereits über 1.200
erfolgreiche Behandlungen durchgeführt
und dabei nach eigenen Angaben eine
Kundenzufriedenheit von 99% erreicht zu
diesem Ziel übrigens auch sehr viele
prominente Persönlichkeiten aber wie
heißt es so schön ein Clip sagt mehr als
1000 Worte seht euch den Unterschied
selbst an der heute mit moderner
haartransplantationstechnik möglich ist
ihr werdet vielleicht auch überrascht
sein die günstig heutzutage eine
Behandlung setzt in Deutschland ist man
muss nicht mehr in die Türkei das große
haartransplantationsmaker reisen um sich
volles ungesundes Haarreifen zu können
mit Hamed ist dies für jeden bequem im
Inland und nach höchsten deutschen
Standards möglich geworden
also falls ihr Interesse habt zögert
nicht klickt auf den Link in der
Beschreibung und informiert euch über
die tollen Möglichkeiten zur Arbeit
Behandlung bei Hamed Mannheim so und nun
zurück zum Lebenslauf unseres
dunkelhaarigen Unterkunft war er
wirklich nur schon immer eine reine
Showman eine Schauspieler und Komiker
nein ganz und gar nicht zwar hat man ihn
vor seiner Wahl immer nur mit der Welt
des schobeses in Verbindung gebracht
aber selinski hat auch einen Jura
Abschluss der Tiere
Wirtschaftsuniversität in der Tasche er
ist also die Putin von Hause aus erstmal
Jurist und das ist nicht alles denn
bevor er Präsident wurde war sie Lenski
nicht nur Komiker sondern auch
Unternehmer und das mit einigen Erfolg
schon als Schüler hatte ein Team für
gewöhne aufgestellt das war ein in der
Sowjetunion hoch populärer Comedy
Mannschaftswettbewerb überne heißt
übrigens Club der fröhlichen und
gebissen und ist bis heute eine enorm
erfolgreiche Fernsehshow in der
Humoristen Teams aus verschiedenen
Städten gegeneinander antreten
silvanskys Team hieß 55 Quartal also das
95 Stadtviertel merkt euch bitte diesen
banalen Namen eines Neubauviertel seine
Heimatstadt er wird später noch wichtig
werden
[Musik]
nun selensky und seine Freunde haben
sich so gut geschlagen dass ich schon im
Jahr 2002 beschlossen eine
Produktionsfirma fast gleichen Namens zu
gründen das Studio Quartal 95 wir reden
hier nicht von einer kleinen
Produktionsfirma die Hochzeitsvideos
oder sowas dreht um euch eine
Vorstellung zu geben diese Firma stammt
hinter der ukrainischen Version von Star
dance in der außer linski als Tänzer
auftrat und sie produzierte einige
andere erfolgreiche TV-Formate der
ebenso sagte die charmante selinsky war
damals schon ein gut bekannter TV
Entertainer so und jetzt haltet euch
fest das war er nämlich nicht nur in der
Ukraine nein das war er auch in Russland
zwei mal hintereinander 2013 und 2014
moderierte er zusammen mit den
russischen Homos Superstar Maxim galt
sogar die Silvestershow des ersten
Kanals in Moskau eine wahre Kultsendung
mit gigantischen Einschaltquoten im
ganzen explodiertischen Raum
[Applaus]
übrigens der Herr der sich da gerade im
Publikum so kultmäßig amüsiert hat ist
Putins heutiger oberster TV Hassprediger
Wladimir sobolio ganz genau das ist
gerade mal zehn Jahre her tja Leute so
ändern sich die Zeiten ironischerweise
haben selbst einige der russischen
Regisseure und Produzenten mit den
selinski eng zusammengearbeitet hat wie
Marat Basar auf uns Haring Andreas an
den russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine öffentlich gefeiert aber es war
nicht diese partysendungen diese lenskys
Karriere das zahnräubchen aufsetzten das
war die TV-Serie mit dem Titel Diener
des Volkes die zwischen 2015 und 19
ausgestrahlt wurde in dieser Politik
Parodie spielzeugenski die Rolle eines
einfachen Kieler geschützt Lehrers
dieser lässt mal während einer unter der
Stunde ordentlich Dampf ab über die
durch und durch korrupte ukrainische
Politik und dann passiert ist seine
Schüler hatten diesen Wutausbruch
heimlich gefilmt und luden ihn auf
Youtube hoch dann haben sie ihren Lehrer
auch noch gleich als
Präsidentschaftskandidaten registriert
das Video geht an viral und weil sich
die Oligarchen im Lande nicht auf einen
anderen Kandidaten einigen können und
das Volk den Hals gestrichen voll hat
von der allgegenwärtigen Korruption wird
der kleine Lehrer schließlich Präsident
der Ukraine so zumindest liegt der Plot
in dieser Politik Parodie aber auch in
der polit Realität gab diese Serie
selenski den entscheidenden Impuls in
die Politik zu gehen er gründete der
Einfachheit halber eine Partei mit den
gleichen Namen wie die Serie selbst also
Diener des Volkes und dann kandidierte
er mit seinem gesammelten darum bei den
echten Wahlen keine Frage selenski war
schon damals ein echter Fernseh Liebling
dem es nicht an Charisma fehlte aber gab
es trotz dieses großen Sprungbrett noch
andere Faktoren die zu seinem Sieg
beigetragen haben
nun dazu müssen wir den sozialen Kontext
der damaligen Ukraine berücksichtigen
das Land war bereits 2014 von Russland
überfallen worden man erinnere sich die
Krim und der Donbass aber das war nicht
das Entscheidende die Ukraine waren
extrem unzufrieden mit ihrer politischen
Klasse im gleichen Jahr hatte die
Revolution der würde auch euromeidan
genannt Ihnen eine neue Ukraine
versprochen näher an Europa und frei von
Korruption doch obwohl einige Reformen
durchgeführt wurden wurde das Problem
der Korruption nie wirklich angegangen
man könnte sagen dass die Ukraine in der
Praxis das gleiche Land über den
gleichen alten Problemen geblieben war
nur die Gesichter hatten sich verändert
viele Ukraine hatten damals das Gefühl
dass einfach nur korrupte pro russische
Politiker durch ebenso große westliche
Politiker ersetzt worden waren der Frust
im Land war gewaltig 2019 gaben knapp
60% der Bürger an mit Präsident
proschenko sehr unzufrieden zu sein die
Ukraine hatte den Übergang zur freien
kapitalistischen Marktwirtschaft immer
noch nicht abgeschlossen und Korruption
war weiterhin die Norm darüber haben wir
entführen wir sollten ten Politik Videos
schon ausführlich berichtet und ich
werde sie euch natürlich verlinken
Events geht das Hauptproblem der Ukraine
wieder in Russland noch im Westen
sondern in der Korruption und den
verkommenen Establishment ich bin kein
Politiker ich bin ein ganz normaler Typ
der kommt um das System zu brechen wolle
die meersalensky nur wenige
politexperten haben damals erwartet dass
er linski überhaupt gewinnen würde er
erschien er als Kuriosum doch dann kam
die Überraschung Faust dick Komiker
errinkt Erdrutsch Sieg bei ukrainischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen Pedro poroschenko
gespielt seine Niederlage ein während
Ski über 70% der Stimmen erhält und
verspricht ich werde es nicht vermasseln
die bereits gesagt selinskys Wahlkampf
war von einem starken
antishmen-kurs geprägt
und wenn wir hier vom establishmen
sprechen dann meinen wir vor allem
korrupte Politiker milliardenschwere
Oligarchen und die sichtbaren und
unsichtbaren Verbindungen zwischen ihnen
kurz um den Filz resiliensky war die
oberste Priorität also schon immer die
Bekämpfung der Korruption und die
Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft der Ukraine
etwas zu verwandeln das Wort deren
europäischen Standards entspricht ich
werde euch von der Ukraine meiner Träume
erzählen es ist eine Ukraine in der es
nur eine Stunde dauert ein Unternehmen
zu gründen in der es 15 Minuten dauert
einen Pass zu bekommen und in der es nur
eine Sekunde dauert bei Wahlen
abzustimmen wo Ärzte und Lehrer echte
Gehälter und korrupte Beamte echte
Gefängnisstrafen bekommen hier sieht
selenskys Programm war schlicht aber
effektiv eine schlanke effiziente
Bürokratie die Modernisierung der
Ukraine und vor allem das Ende der
Korruption aber was kam danach waren das
alles nur wahlkampfversprechend das
Blaue vom Himmel die üblichen Wolken
kuckucksheime nun als frisch Gestalter
Staatschef hat das geht tatsächlich
versucht seine Versprechen zu erfüllen
so hat er zum Beispiel eine Reform
eingeführt die die Immunität von
Abgeordneten aufhoben auch wenn gerade
das in einem normalen Staat eine
ziemlich fragwürdige Maßnahme gewesen
wäre schließlich handelt es sich dabei
um ein etabliertes demokratisches
Institut aber das wäre ein Thema für ein
anderes Video außerdem führte er ein
Misstrauensvotum ein das ist den
Parlament ermöglicht den Präsidenten aus
dem anzuheben erscheinte damit also
quasi seine eigenen macht ein und ein
Beispiel aus dem Wirtschaftssektor
selinski unterzeichnete ein Gesetz zur
Liberalisierung des Handels mit
Agrarland und das war keine Frage ein
großer Schritt gegen die Oligarchen und
für den Übergang der Ukraine zu einem
Kapitalismus im Stile ihre westlichen
Nachbarn doch wir sollten auch die
Schattenseiten nicht ausblenden
es sich nicht nehmen an die 30 Freunde
aus seiner ehemaligen Produktionsfirma
Quartal von 95 in die Regierung zu holen
und auch wenn jeder Politiker erstmal
eine starke Hausmacht braucht um sein
Programm überhaupt durchsetzen zu können
da ist natürlich verdächtig nach einer
neuen Runde der altbewährten
fettenwirtschaft aus aber nicht nur das
er wurde auch kritisiert weil er in den
berüchtigten Pandora papers auftauchte
sowohl er als auch seine ehemaligen
Kollegen von Quartal 95 besaßen offshore
Firmen und Immobilien in London aber
diesen Punkt müssen wir fair sein es ist
natürlich kein Verbrechen Unternehmen in
Steueroase zu besitzen wenn im Inland
alles korrekt versteuert wird und in
Ländern mit so wenig Rechtssicherheit
wie den meisten Post sowjetischen
Staaten ist das sogar fast schon Pflicht
es ist im Grunde genommen ein Weg sich
den Zugriff der lokalen seinschaften zu
entziehen und sich auch völlig legale
Weise abzusichern denn in einem durch
und durch korrupten Land wird man durch
solch einen Schritt eher weniger
erpressbar schließlich war seine Ski vor
seiner Karriere als Politiker einer der
erfolgreichsten Fernseher Entertainer
der Ukraine und auch als Unternehmer in
Branche tätig mit seiner Beteiligung an
der Produktionsfirma die seine
Fernsehserie und viele andere Hits
produziert hat hat er eben ganz legal
und ordentlich ein paar Millionen
verdient so wie dies komikerkollegen
Allah Stefan Raab oder Jerry Seinfeld in
ihren Ländern auch getan haben und ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass einem ein
Steuer- bzw Vermögensberater in der
politisch instabilen Ukraine dazu raten
wird zumindest ein Teil davon im Ausland
aufzubewahren man weiß ja nie was
passiert daher sind die Angriffe auf
selenski bezüglich seiner offshorten
unserer Meinung nach substanziell nicht
begründet fragwürdiger war da schon
selenskys connection zu igoroski einem
Bekannten ukrainischen
Unternehmer einer der
hauptgeschäftspartnerin und auch der
Hauptunterstützer seiner Wahlkampagne
gegen diesen Mann wurde jedoch in
Korruptionsfällen ermittelt und er war
auch schon verurteilt worden Jahre lang
lebte er in Exil um nicht ins Gefängnis
zu lassen
hätte er dann in die Ukraine zurück und
gebannt mehrere gewichtsverfahren vor
der Weise denn Präsidenten
Fernsehsender finanziert die eng mit der
TV-Produktionsfirma Studio Quartal 95
verbunden waren allerdings hat sich die
Beziehung zwischen selensky und
colomäusky seitdem abgekühlt im Jahr
2019 wurde colomäuskie von der
ukrainischen Regierung beschuldigt im
Zusammenhang mit dem insolventen
privatbank-skandal
illegal Gelder aus der Bank entnommen zu
haben wir haben darüber bereits 2021 in
einem Video berichtet selensky und seine
Regierung haben sich in der Folge von
colomäuskie distanziert und seine
Rückkehr in die ukrainische
Geschäftswelt blockiert
und natürlich kamen auch manch andere
Zweifel auf kurzum wir können
konstatieren das selenski vor den Krieg
die sehr hohen Erwartungen der Ukraine
bereits enttäuscht hatte zunächst war er
tatsächlich einer der beliebtesten
Politiker des Landes gewesen doch dann
stürzte er in den Umfragen ab schaut es
euch an das Ende der selensky
Alternative die Umfragen vom Oktober
2021 waren ein Schock für das Team des
Präsidenten selinskys Zustimmungswerte
als Präsident vielen von 33,3 % im
September auf 24,7 % im Oktober doch
just das war der Moment als immer öfter
von einer drohenden russischen Invasion
in der Ukraine gesprochen wurde vor
allem die USA warnten lauthals denn sie
ordneten immer stärkere russische
Truppenkontingente in Grenzwerte
Salewski nun er musste erst einmal
reichlich Kritik einstecken denn der
ukrainische Präsident behamster die Lage
und zeigte sich lange davon überzeugt
dass es keine Invasion geben würde ich
weiß dass viele Leute dachten ich würde
vielleicht übertreiben aber wusste dass
wir Informationen hatten die dafür
sprachen das Putin über die Grenze
kommen würde daran gab es keinen Zweifel
aber selensky und viele andere wollten
es nicht hören ich verstehe warum sie es
nicht hören wollten aber am Ende ist es
doch passiert US-Präsident Joe Biden am
24 Februar 2022 nahm die Sache dann eine
dramatische Wendung das war der Tag der
alles veränderte schauen wir uns also an
diese darauf an diesen Schlüssel Datum
reagierte
[Musik]
spaß beiseite der Comedian wird Bier
ernst
am 24 Februar 2022 bestätigte sich was
befürchtet worden war sich viele aber
nicht vorstellen konnten oder wollten
Russland drang mit seiner Streitmacht
von mehreren Seiten in seinen seit 30
Jahren bestehenden souveränen
Nachbarstadt ein und brachte Tod und
Zerstörung über die Ukraine kaum jemand
dachte dass die Ukraine effektiv
Widerstand leisten könnte das
Kräfteverhältnis zwischen den
ukrainischen und russischen
Streitkräften schien ihr keine Chance zu
lassen und westliche Führer boten diese
lensky Hilfe an wenn er aus dem Land
fliehen wollte machen wir es uns noch
einmal klar hätte Russland Kiew
eingenommen was damals als sehr
Wahrscheinlichkeit wäre selensky als
erster verhaftet und vielleicht sogar
umgebracht worden unter diesen Umständen
erwarteten wohl alle dass er linski die
beide in die Hand nimmt es wäre nicht
das erste Mal gewesen dass du etwas in
Kiew passiert sein Vorgänger Viktor
Janukowitsch war während der EURO mal
dann Unruhen aus der Ukraine geflohen
und zwar nach Russland vor seinem
eigenen Volk und das war wohl auch der
Unterschied zu selenski denn in diesem
hochgradig kritischen Momente sagte
bologneselenski einen Satz der wohl
jetzt schon in die Geschichte
eingegangen ist ich brauche Munition
keine Mitfahrgelegenheit noch
schwieriger als einer Gefangennahme zu
gehen war allerdings eine brutalen
Invasion durch eine viel größere Armee
zu widerstehen
[Musik]
selensky blieb also und es war nicht nur
der pure Mut der Verzweiflung der ihn
auf seine Posten hielt umgehend nutzte
er den dramatischen Moment und bereite
Unterstützung für sein Land zu gewinnen
ab sofort verbreitete er die Parole hält
uns dann deren wir die Angreifer ab und
wir werden siegen fakt ist selensky hat
damit die uneingeschränkte Unterstützung
der NATO gewonnen plötzlich war sein
unscheinbares Land das hier noch 2021
kam auch Anhieb auf der Karte gefunden
hätten ins Zentrum des politischen
Schachbretts gerückt ich meine manche
sagen ja jetzt ach das wusste doch jeder
dass der Westen der Ukraine zu Hilfe
kommen würde nein eine Wahrheit war das
überhaupt nicht klar man erinnere sich
nur an den deutschen Minister Christian
Lindner der als erstes vom ukrainischen
Botschafter wissen wollte wie man am
besten Kontakt zur neuen von Putin
eingesetzten Marionettenregierung in
Kiew aufnehmen könne ja genau das war
die Erwartungshaltung nur dank der
Sturheit selenskys und seiner Regierung
und den hartnäckigen Widerstand der
ukrainischen Armee öffneten sich die
Tore des Solidarität im Westen Werft man
einen Blick auf diese Grafik hier seht
ihr alle der Ukraine geleistete Hilfe
der bedeutendsten Spender sowohl in Form
von Geld und humanitärer Hilfe als auch
in Form von Waffen und Militär
Ausrüstung die Vereinigte Staaten sind
mit Abstand führend aber auch die
Europäische Union hat eine Menge Geld
auf den Tisch gelegt um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen wobei diese Beträge nicht
alles sind die von einem Konflikt
ausgelöste Energiekrise die Europa seit
dem Sommer durchmacht hat nicht minder
viele Milliarden verschlungen und die
Flüchtlingswelle war auch nicht ohne für
die Aufnahme starten stellte sie eine
große Belastung da
[Musik]
natürlich ist es im Interesse des
gesamten bestens dass die Ukraine diesen
Krieg gewinnt oder zumindest nicht
verliert um es klar zu sagen die
Lieferung von Waffen an die Ukraine ist
die günstigste Investition die Europa
und die USA in Sachen Sicherheit tätigen
können im Kosten nutzenvergleich von
investierten Geld zu erreichen zum
Effekt dürfte die Militärhilfe an die
Ukraine wurde den effizientesten
Regierungsprogrammen aller Zeiten zählen
ja das meine ich ernst denn mit jeder
Minute Widerstand verliert Russland
geldmaterial und Soldaten so wird es für
Putin immer schwieriger nicht nur
weiteres ukrainisches Direktoriums
erobern sondern auch das zu halten was
er sich bereits gewaltsam unter den
Nagel gerissen hat und nebenbei wird es
Tag für Tag immer unwahrscheinlicher das
Moskau als bald noch andere europäische
Nationen angreifen könnte das bald die
Kommentar oder wohl da will Putin hat
seine Armee in der Ukraine in eine
beispiellose selbstverstümelungsaktion
geführt und je mehr die Ukraine die
russische Armee Schwächen desto weniger
musste Rest Europas selbst aufrüsten tja
so ist die Lage jetzt vor einem Jahr im
Februar März 2022 hat kaum jemand zu
glauben gewagt das Russland ein solcher
Papiertiger ist und nur wenige haben
sich vorstellen können dass sich die
zahlenmäßig weit unterlegene ukrainische
Armee so gut halten kann wie sie es
getan hat warum denn so ist könnt ihr
übrigens in einigen unserer Videos
nachsehen die ich euch in der
Beschreibung verlinkt habe doch zurück
zu er mag viele Schwächen haben aber
seine Überzeugungskraft dürfte als
legendär in die Geschichte eingehen in
den ersten Kriegsmonaten hielt er in
praktisch allen Parlamenten der
nato-länderansprachen per Videoschalte
ab Dezember dann auch persönlich und in
jedem dieser Länder wusste er mit den
richtigen Worten den nervt jeder
einzelnen Nation zu treffen
[Musik]
in den Vereinigten Staaten verglich
selenski die Invasion der Ukraine mit
den Angriffen auf Pearl Harbor und das
World Trade Center als er vor dem
Deutschen Bundestag sprach forderte er
dass man ihm helfen solle diese Mauer
niederzureißen bezog sich dabei auf eine
von Russland errichtete Mauer gegen die
Freiheit dies war natürlich eine klare
Anspielung auf die Berliner Mauer und
Ronald Reagans mythische Rede am
Brandenburger Tor schließlich war die
Mauer und Grenze die ganz Deutschland
teilte schon auf geheißt moskauz
errichtet worden da überrascht es nicht
mehr dass er ins Gesicht an die
britengewand auf Churchill und dessen
kampfgeist-brief ihr wisst schon Blut
Schweiß und Tränen in bester Churchill
Maria Versicherte selenski in London die
Ukraine würden viel Irland kämpfen koste
es was es wolle an den Stränden auf den
Feldern und auf den Straßen
tja was für ein pia-talent werden da
manche von euch sagen ja da habt ihr
recht mir scheint selensky wäre mit
seiner überzeugungsgabe auch in der Lage
Eskimos Eis zu verkaufen oder den Sonys
Fußbodenheizungen aber genau ein solches
Talent hat die Ukraine gebraucht und
braucht es noch immer nur da dieser
Kommunikationsstrategie konnte die
Ukraine und ihre Armee eine gewaltige
Menge an humanitärer finanzieller und
militärische Hilfe zur Stabilisierung
und Verteidigung ihres Landes bekommen
und nicht nur das silenski hat es auch
geschafft die ukrainische Bevölkerung
zum Widerstand zum inspirieren noch mal
das alles scheint uns heute
offensichtlich und selbstverständlich zu
sein aber wie war es darum im Februar
2022 tatsächlich bestellt
selensky hat seit Beginn der Invasion
faktischen Nacht für Nacht seinen
Bürgern in den sozialen Medien Mut
gemacht und sie zum Kampf motiviert und
das nicht etwa tief aus irgendeinem
unker wohl die ganze Welt hat über seine
Videos aus dem Straßen von Kiew gestaunt
während der russische Armee vor den
stadtburgen Stand legendäre Botschaften
wie diese haben der ukrainischen
Gesellschaft Hoffnung und
Widerstandsgeist gegeben
der Optimismus ist damit noch nicht am
Ende er ist bereits auf der Suche nach
Investoren für den Wiederaufbau in der
Nachkriegszeit
selensky ruft Investoren zu einer
langfristigen Zusammenarbeit mit der
Ukraine auf bis jetzt ist das nicht mal
schlecht gelaufen es ist ihm bereits
gelungen Blackrock den weltgrößten
Verwalter von Investmentfonds davon zu
überzeugen ihn zu beraten und Investoren
zu finden und nicht nur das selenski
schlug im September persönlich die
eröffnungsglocke an der New Yorker Börse
um eine investitionskampagne zu starten
wobei er behauptet man habe bereits
damit begonnen wieder aufzubauen was
Russland zerstört hat gut zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt wissen wir wahrlich noch nicht
wie viele Investoren bereits an werden
auf die Ukraine zu setzen aber eines
können wir schon sagen im militärischen
Bereich hat dieses Land eine Wunder
vollbracht und wir müssen ein erkennen
dass er lensky persönlich einen guten
Teil dieses Verdienstes für sich
beanspruchen kann
[Musik]
ukrainische Armee hat tausende
Quadratkilometer des von Russland
zunächst eingenommen Gebiet
zurückerobert es ist ihr gelungen die
Angreifer zum Rückzug aus den Gebieten
Kiew und einem Teil der oblastung zu
bewegen und sie hat es sogar geschafft
Raketen und Drohnenangriffe auf die Krim
und das russische Wunderland
durchzuführen wir können selensky also
mit gutem Recht für seine Erfolge feiern
aber wie ich anfangs auch gesagt habe
dieser Präsident hat in seinen ersten
Amtsjahren auch einige Schattenseiten
gezeigt heißt das jedoch dass erlensky
unseren Applaus nicht verdienen würde
nun ganz und gar nicht seine Leistungen
in diesem ersten Kriegs ja garantieren
ihm einen ehrenvollen Platz in den
Geschichtsbücher wir sollten uns dennoch
da verhüten ihn zum Messias zu erklären
der nun in einem auferst die Ukraine
Osteuropa und vielleicht auch noch ganz
Russland auf ewig von der Gefahr des
putinismus oder des russischen
Imperialismus befreien könnte und im
Moment kämpft er nicht nur knallhart
gegen Putin sondern kehrt auch mit dem
Stahlbesen die Korruption vor der
eigenen Haustür aus um die Ukraine Fett
für die EU zu machen und das scheint ihm
gar nicht mal schlecht zu gelingen aber
das ist ein Thema für ein weiteres Video
denn jetzt seit erstmal ihr an der Reihe
uns eure Meinung zu sagen wird selensky
uns doch noch enttäuschen ist er wie
manche behaupten einen falscher Messias
zu Unrecht zur heißgestalt erklärt oder
vielleicht doch eine Art neuer Churchill
dieser kriegsprämie der sein Land der
erfolgreich gerettet hat wurde von
diesem nach dem gewonnen Krieg
schließlich abgewählt also wir sind wie
immer auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch etwas daraus gelernt
habt falls ja geht uns bitte ein Like
heißt mit euren Freunden und vergesst
nicht das Abo mit wirklich um keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir es auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit der es
hält dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]